here's a big one if you're not feeling
it find new friends I'm being dead
serious about this this one is real big
for me who you hang out with is a huge
Yannick and these are all tried and true
things right we've heard the you're the
whatever of the five friends you spent
like that's real that's that one put in
the bank like if you're not feeling it
you need to go to meetup.com and go to
ten meetups of people that are hungry
like it's unbelievable what happened to
me when I got into the Silicon Valley
world and started meeting like Mark
Zuckerberg and like ever Williams and
socket like Travis like it changed my
life this town actually fun for me to
tell the story here South by Southwest
2007 changed my life because I hung out
I forced myself to go to a web 2.0 which
later became social media the current
City Internet conference South by
Southwest and I was looking at all these
kids and by the way this is when tech
wasn't cool
straight [ __ ] nerds but they were
trying to change it they weren't here
for kicks and giggles they weren't here
to hook up they were here to like change
the world like I'm going to build a
product that is going to be in every
single person's hand like and they have
like the Twitter's and Facebook's movers
they did and and uh and it was biggest
impact in my career and it's something I
think a lot about now
so anyway real practical if you feel
motivated by this conversation or you're
intrigued by it and one new winner
friend like you know what I mean had one
new winner friend and cut one loser
friend like yeah I know he's been your
boy since fourth grade but he sits at
home and [ __ ] smokes weed and plays
2k all day like you can only love them
so much go home
cut one cut your leisure loser friend
and go find a winner friend go like go
somewhere go somewhere like go to like
go go to meetup.com go to a Facebook
group join some [ __ ] DM the 800 people
that you think are make sure they're not
bullshitting they're like doing what you
want and just make one new friend I see
it like Barack like he's right like
it's unbelievable to watch my team like
they get faster to get smarter they get
more confident right it's real man it's
real confidence and like hunger gets
passed on to each other
it's like teen dynamics it's why like a
great player that sucks [ __ ] can [ __ ] a
team up like go audit your circle add
one more winner increase one more losers
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]